hello my name is Michael today I'm going
to talk about the relationships between
learning and pseudonym generators
computable in constant power time
decision to work with shuchiha
again this work is about relationships
between learning and pseudonymous
lovely speaking running is a task to
find information hidden in data by
contrast pseudonymous is a string
indistinguishable from a random but
generated from a very short scene
and if we already got a runner as an
underwater and if we regard hidden
information as random seed then these
two things says opposite to God
that's why the natural question is can
we guarantee easy running or suit
Randomness we meet argument
in other words can we obtain the
equivalence results between hardness of
running and existence of pseudo-random
generator
fortunately we know that the answer is
yes
one implication from the existence
absolute random generator to harness
running dates back the very first paper
in computational running salary by
variant and he showed that the existence
absolute random generator imparts
Hardware chronic
the other direction is by impact
wrapping and brown Frost cantalifter and
they considered the average case harness
of learning to show the other direction
particularly in bfkl they considered
average case variant of popularity so
now let's say AC is a concept class this
is defined as a subset of Boolean bald
function and in term formulation of
average population we consider two
distribution families the first one is
distribution over functions in C
the second one is a user called example
distribution this is a distribution over
input
and we say that an algorithm L is a weak
learner for Class C if so this L is
given sample set this is a set of input
output pairs where f is selected
according to distribution F and each
input a circuit according to D and this
Runner is also given challenge unlabeled
data and this challenge is also circuit
according to the same distribution and
the task of Runa is to Output the level
of challenge with probability greater
than half plus some non-negative Factor
and we usually he called this m at the
sample complexity this is a number of
samples required for running
and they showed that upper educates
hardness of weak running a polynomial
time computable Class C with respect to
some sample distributions
indeed characterizes the existence of
pseudo random generator
okay now let's consider the next
question running simple crosses versus
pseudo Randomness computable in simple
graphs
such a dichotomy is motivated by two
directions
the implication from the existence of
pseudonym generator in simple classes to
harness running simple crosses is
usually called cryptographic harness
running and demonstrated by many Works
in computational running Theory the
other direction from the hardness
running to the existence of pseudonym
generator in simple crosses is motivated
by efficiently computable cryptography
from the hardness Assumption of learning
in fact this motivation is also
mentioned in the work bfkl and their
work is somewhat robust even in such a
simple classes because the drug is based
on the Vernon equivalence result between
unpredictability and pseudo Randomness
and this technique is robust even such a
simple Crossing particularly the
proposed a pseudonym generator
computable in politicized DNS based on
the hardness of running a majority
operas parity and there are other
related works that show the very
efficiently computable cryptographic
premium based on the hardest learning
in this work we consider around the
simplest cases in pseudonym generator we
consider relationships between hardness
of running and polynomial storage to the
random generator computable in
anesthesia it showed pplznc2
polynomial stories in nc0 looks like
this
generated a given and a bit random seed
to a polynomial larger pseudonym string
which is indistinguishable from a
efficiently computer adversaries and
polynomial storage epad comes from here
and we consider pseudonym generator
computable in nc0 it means that
each pseudo random bit only depends on
constant number of random seats and in
this context we usually consider a
correction of PPR dating and c0 where at
initialization step some generative
generators select the description of
pseudo random generator in nc0
and we take into account the random
selection of this D in the argument
such a cryptographic primitive is really
important because of remarkable
applications like as a higher efficient
cryptography where this is also used as
a round of assumptions for constructing
IO in recent breakthrough results but
constructing polynomial starts prgs in
nc0 is relatively harder than other
Primitives in nc0 in the sense that
there is no known construction based on
the very separated work on Randomness
encoding and the known construction for
oprg pprg in nc0 is based on one
framework called garage function and
pseudonym generator
previously the implication from the
existence of pprg in nc0 or other
related Notions to harness of running is
studied by several Works particularly in
recent work by a donery and verdict show
that the hardness of running many
important concept crosses and the
assumption that a polynomial storage
gold iprcs this is a special case of
pseudonym generator in nc2 in this work
we consider the other direction so we
try to find the characterization of the
existence of pprg in nc0 based on the
average case hardness of learning and
some of you might think this is
primitive is characterized by a average
case harness of running and C2 because
of the occupancy result between
unpredictability and pseudo randomness
but this natural conjecture seems
incorrect
because Contracting the pbrg in nc0 is a
very Central challenge in cryptography
but by contrast learning nc0 this is
usually called running a constant filter
is Trivial reliable by using the very
famous Occam's razor despite this
hardness part does not hold
unconditionally
then can we still obtain the
characterization of pprgs in nc0 but is
some hardness of running so this is a
question we consider in this work
okay now let's see our results
so the question is can pplc's in nc0 be
calculated by reliability
the answer is yes by considering a fixed
parameter tractable sample complexity I
mean we considered parameter as a
setting of running we consider
parameterized concept across and
parameterized distributions F and D
and we consider a fpt sample complexity
written like this some computer function
in parameters times some polynomial in m
but note that we do not consider fpt
time complexity so time compressed it
can be like this
and this running setting is justified by
the fact that usually correcting samples
takes much more cost than consuming
computational time and considering
suggestion does not make the problem
trivial because uh for example the
natural conjecture is also the
correspondence between the existence of
people and nc0 and average case harness
of running kfontas is just a function
which only depends on career and
coordinates but running kefunter is
still a runnable with fpt sample so to
characterize the pplcs in nc0 we need to
consider some other non-trivial setting
of running
now let's see our result so first of all
we know that the general result the
equivalence between the existence of
General pseudo random generated and the
average gets hardness of General weak
learning so we tune up these three
settings to obtain the characterization
of the correction of pplc and c0
so we considered average case harness of
weak running with fpt samples where the
concept class is 6 Plus F2 polynomials
this is just a summation of C monomials
in F2
and we consider a distribution of a
functions sample by depth G circuits so
this is where natural parameter and many
natural or uniform distribution over
functions can be some PowerPoint in this
setting in many cases
another example distribution we consider
some Parable and C Prime's first
distribution where C spars mean that the
harming weight of supported string is
bounded by the parameter and running
under such a sparse distribution
naturally it captured the setting of
running with a rarely occurred features
and the average guitar lesson will be
grounding with fpg samples where
parameters is so DC DNC Prime
characterizes the existence of
Correction of pptc and c0
in clinical speaking two characters the
correction on PPL digits in nc0 we need
to consider a distribution on example
distributions rather than the just fixed
example distribution but this part just
makes the hardest assumption easier to
hold than the fixed one
and we also obtain the same
capitalization result even for other
Central classes like I said see through
response functions
and Deputy Prime partition trees and
this is additional trees where at
internal node we can ask some party
and we can also obtain the same
calculation result for all FC prime or
addition to it
I think this is a less studied concept
request but this is very natural to
represent some concept because we can
make a decision according to a querying
or
and our results also hold in a super
polynomial resin for example if we
consider a sub-exponential average case
how does a weak running in this setting
then we can obtain sub-exponential
secure pprgs in nc0
and by this characterization result if
we especed by some parameterized
distribution F and D satisfying this uh
constraint then we and if we assume the
objectives weak running with fpd samples
then we can construct a correction of
pprgs in nc0 this enables a running
theoretic approach to constructing ppts
in nc0 so I think this is the high part
of this study
but unfortunately this serum itself is
very general result and this does not
specify any specific F and D this is a
very important feature direction is to
find such a good candidates for f and D
to construct pprgs in mc0 and in this
box we propose a natural candidate
running random party decision trees
we're at random party decision three is
defined like this so This D is just a
parameter and each internal node we ask
party e on randomly circuited subsets
and each reef is labeled by a random
values and as far as I know the hundreds
of learning random pretty decision trees
is consistent with our current knowledge
in computational learning theory
and if this problem is hard on for
example a uniform distribution of a
slice strings with fixed harming weight
then we can obtain the correction of
pprd in nc0 by using our result
and importance of running random party
decision trees is in fact in our work we
also consider other related calculation
results so we characterize the pbrts in
other related classes by considering the
hardness of running and if this problem
is hard on a uniform distribution then
it yields a single pprd in party and
Caesar where we allow one party gate
with unbounded finding at the top
and even if this problem is hard under
some uh some variable distribution very
general setting this year's correction
on pprgs in a party e mc0 in any cases
the average case hardness of running a
random party decision trees yet some
very efficiently computable polynomials
to the random generators in this sense
this problem is really important problem
and running feltic cryptographic
analysis of running random part Edition
trees seems really important open
program
okay now let's see the proof techniques
approve is based on your addition which
was considered in several previous works
and we consider this realization in fpt
setting
particularly we Define realization of
Class C as a two polynomial time
computable function D and H 35
certifying the following
now we have across C and binary strings
a one function Maps each binary
representation of crust to some binary
string
and the other function Maps string to
Binary representation of a function in
Cross C in fpt setting
so each function f is mapped to some
string
F star and we call this as if Star as a
URL of F and each string X is mapped to
extra and this is a function and we call
this as a dual of x
the requirement is for every function in
the class and for every input
the operation function is equal to the
evaluation of QR
and in fact for all capitalizing ppts in
nc0 we need to compute these uh DN H in
nc0 for example let's see the case of
utilization of C plus X before leading
like this formula and we naturally
assume that this polynomial is
represented by this coefficient and one
mapping from a polynomial to student is
just a concatenation
and another mapping from string to
polynomial is based on this very simple
equation where we regard each so this X
as a coefficient and we construct
another mapping based on this area where
we regard X as coefficient and it it is
not hard to see is that this polynomial
is also six plus
the reason why we consider the
graduation is because the radiation is
really natural notion to connect
hardness of learning and cryptographic
Notions
because in running public information is
input user called examples and secretary
information is a function the runner
tries to learn
by contrast in crypto the public
information is a function that computes
The cryptographic Primitives and the
secret to information is input user
called random seed
so to connect the harness of learning to
some crypto we need some kind of
duration notion to change the input path
to a function and to change the function
part to input and in fact if we have
authorization defined in the previous
slide we can easily show that
equivalence between the harness running
and pprg particularly on one hand if the
harness of running hot then we can
obtain unpredictable sample sets
and by considering the Dual of this
sample setting we can construct some
kind of pseudonym generator where each X
is changed to functions and so the
hidden function f is regarded as a
random seed and each output bit
corresponds to each level
but unfortunately this f-star is usually
not distributed at uniform random so to
construct random generator we need to
consider section according to F and the
computation of QR is also a part of
pseudonym generator
and in our case we consider F sample in
nc0 and in such a case the number of
random seeds is bounded by some fpt
function because each bit of the
representation of f only depends on
constant number of randomness
so by taking sufficient and large a fpta
sample complexity we can obtain
polynomial storage and complexity of
generator is just a concatenation of c
and the complexity of computing URL and
complexity of F and in our case this is
a nc0 and this is also nc0
on the other hand if we have some
polynomial storage a pseudonym generator
and by considering the Dual of this
generator we can obtain unpredictable
sample set where the target function is
dual of a random seed
but this argument only here the harness
of running with fixed sample complexity
so if sample complexity is much smaller
than the storage of the generator then
by considering uniform distribution over
these samples we can show that the
hardness of running with fixed sample
complexity and to enhance this to fpt
sample complexity we use the well-known
ggm construction and assumption on
polynomial threats
particularly in DDM construction we
apply this original generator again
again to enhance the storage of the
generator and roughly speaking the
number of applications affect the
exponent in storage
but by contrast this number of
applications only affects multiple
category in Sample complexity if we
consider fpt sample complexity that's
why if we apply the original generator
according to this DGM construction then
we can prepare enough large example uh
so unpredictable sample sets and we can
show that the hardness of running with
fpt sample complexity
Because by the remaining part is to show
the duration in involved in nc0 because
if this part is nc0 then we can obtain
pprd in nc0
but unfortunately we cannot hope for
such a
self-realization of any season in other
words so we cannot get
this kind of duration
to the strings and from a storing
caffeine
lovely speaking this is because
evaluating careful requires at least
super constant bit information or
function itself and we can justify this
by augment on communication complexity
that's why we need to change at least
one part and we must consider non-self
visualization involved in carefunter
and the question is how we get such a no
self-utualization involving nc0
our idea for this is to use
self-dualization of super classes of
energy
so if we consider the radiation of
Supercross of energy zero okay filter
then the care center part must be mapped
some subgras of strings
and if this top graph is also mapped to
some careful
then we can use visualization of
supergrass as authorization of nc0
and in our case this type of graph is
spur strings and we cover such a
additional substructure as a fundus pass
condition so careful is mapped to some
sports strings and some splastering is
mapped to carefully
and by using a duration with such a fun
test pass condition we can obtain the
equivalence result between hardness of
running on Spurs distribution and the
existence of pplcs in nc0
and this idea yields a better theorem of
our Amazon
so we Define that parameters Class C is
fpt direct relatable in nc0 with
Hunter's pass condition like this so
there exists two functions computable in
any c0 such that it satisfy the
condition of QR and each K Hunter is
contained in grass and harming weight of
the Dual of kefunta is bounded by some
constant in fpt sense and for every
string with a bounded Hamming weight and
if we consider that you are of such a
string then this must be e filter
and for example we can easily verify
that the previous duration of 6 Plus F2
poly satisfied the fundus pass condition
beautifully speaking if this is first
then harming rate of this part is
constant and this word is constant and
so this is a center function and vice
versa
and we can show that The Meta theorem so
it fixed states that if parameters Cross
C is fpt realizable in nc0 with Winter's
pass condition
then their average gets hardness of such
crust with fpt samples under the sysplas
distribution and nc0 sampling
distribution f
calculated the existence of Correction
on pprgs in nc0
and our main CRM is shown by this metal
theorem and by considering such a fpt
dualization in mc0 with juntas pass
condition 406 plus f240 C free response
polynomials and that's the variance of
addition to rates
and the importance of this meta cell
Name Is by using this meta theorem we
can reduce the task of characterizing a
correction of pprgs in nc0
to some study on Boolean function
because you know
finding visualization in nc0 with a
fundus pass condition is really positive
problem on representation of Boolean
functions particularly if we try to find
a new characterization based on our
method what you only have to do is just
solve such a positive problem and in
fact you do not need to know anything
about running or pseudonym generators
to sum up in this work we consider the
characterization of the existence of
Correction of pplgs in nc0 but the
average case harness of weak running
with fpt samples and this enables a new
running theoretic approach to construct
such a pprgz and c0 and in fact our main
theorem is derived from The Meta theorem
where we consider the notion of fpt
utilization in encision with juntas pass
condition
and I also mentioned some open programs
the uh first interesting open question
is to find other characterization based
on our meta server and finding other
useful substructures the fundus pass
conditions might be also interesting
particularly such a result materials
another characterization of ppis in c0
by using different class of example
distributions
it is also important to find a good
candidate for all D and F to construct
pprgs in nc0
and the final important question is a
learning Authority or cryptographic
analysis of running random partition
trees as I mentioned before
okay thank you for attention